Well, here we are at Museum of Modern Art
and, believe it or not, it's the Club 57 Show.
I was one of the founding members of the club,
and it's a real honor to be here after being
in a church basement in the '70s for so many
years.
If you really want to get an idea of what the scene was like,
you can stand in front of this wall of photographs and get the feeling
We were having fun, we were being transgressive
Here, all of these scenes converged.
We have John Waters.
We had School of Visual Arts, a lot of us
went to School of Visual Arts, a lot of us
met in San Francisco.
So, we all converged, and we were the rejects
and we had to find a place to play.
We weren't fitting in the punk scene, we weren't
fitting in the gay scene, so we kind of had
to make our own scene.
This is Club 57.
This is the door of the Polish church right
here.
Now it's a mental health center, which kind
of, like, makes sense to me because it was
quite a mental institution when we were there.
Unfortunately, so many of these people are
not with us today, so it's bittersweet.
Darling, how are you?
How are you?.
Thanks so much for doing this.
Oh, sure, thanks for asking.
It's always the kids in the basement
The first time I ever went to the Club, we
had been rehearsing for New Wave Vaudeville
at Irving Plaza, and Susan Hannaford and Tom
Scully said, "Frank, do you wanna go down
and see this little club, this space that
we're thinking about putting the Monster Movie
Club in," and I said, "Sure."
So, we went down there, and I was like, "Where
am I?"
There was a gate, and you had to go...this
little lock, it was dusty, and there were
cobwebs everywhere.
And Susan said, "Well, what do you think,
Frank," and I said, "Paint it black," and
we did.
And that's...I think we opened, like, within
two weeks.
We have many performances, this one is the
lady wrestling night.
This was an off-shoot of the Ladies' Auxiliary.
They would meet every week, and they would
discuss issues and what they wanted to do.
They would...I'm sorry, that's Wendy Wild
with her breasts.
They would score on who they had slept with
that week, and they would get points.
And, if they slept with a gay guy, they got
extra points.
This was the Ladies' Auxiliary here, and they
started a group called Pulsallama, and they
did something, Min is the "Bonefinder" and,
"Find that bone, find that bone, find that
bone, find that bone."
And then, of course, there was Klaus Nomi.
He dressed like this all the time.
He was at Fiorucci, but he was an opera singer
so he was legit.
It was very odd that somebody could actually
sing, because talent was not required.
That was what was good about it, you didn't
have to have any talent.
You wanted to be a rock and roll star?
All right, go be it.
We'll pretend like you are the star for $25.
I did this piece, this was a piece called
"TVC15".
It was named after the David Bowie movie "Man
Who Fell to Earth".
There was the blackout in the '70s.
I was in front of Crazy Eddie's, and there
was a line of television sets, and right when
the blackout happened all of the TVs just
went off.
Let's go down, and there's...it even gets
crazier down here.
It's like we're descending into the bowels
of the Club.
This was also over the bar in the later period,
the idea of America.
This is John Sex's wall.
You can see how he really took over some kind
of visual presence in the Lower East Side,
in the Village, in the East Village.
It was hypersexual, it was hyper-celebrity,
it was shiny, it was Day-Glo, it was colorful,
it was transgressive.
By Kenny Scharf, this is "Cosmic Closet".
This is a new piece, but he's been developing
this sensibility ever since 1970.
Kenny always kept it about fun, and he always
loved his black-light experience.
Ann had to make up a calendar for every month.
So, she started with a very basic format,
and filling in as it was booked.
And, as you can see, they got progressively
and progressively more popular, and every
night was taken
We had Monster Nazi, The Flesh Eaters, and
The Frozen Dead.
We had Playboy Bunny Night.
We had "Bring Your Own Video".
So, these are very, very important, and she
did such a beautiful job with these.
And, as I always said, we didn't live for
the future, we lived for tonight.
That's about as far as we went, "What are
we gonna do tonight?"
This is a painting I did for "Age of Insects".
It was a science-fiction movie that Eric Marciano
did.
They looked through the eye at people.
He paid me two grams of cocaine for this one,
right, and it's hanging in MoMA now.
I want at least two more grams.
These are Kenny's paintings.
I first saw Kenny's paintings...always, like,
some, you know, black and white, heavy-duty
kid, and he was making these paintings which
were...I went, "What are you doing?
What are these?"
You know, this was very LA.
Kenny was from Beverly Hills, and he brought
that with him.
He always had a different edge, a very California
vibe.
I love these paintings.
Another aspect of the Club was theater started
happening there.
There was performance, there was film being
shot there, and then theater people started
coming down.
There was Scott Wittman and Marc Shaiman,
who went on to write "Hairspray" and many
other great musicals.
They started there.
My favorite one was "Trojan Women".
It was a musical, and it ran forever.
It was so popular, it really started bringing
a lot of star power into the Club.
They would line up, I saw it 100 times, and
I still scream and laugh when I watch it.
Of course here we have Keith, and you know the iconic three eyes, and the running baby
When he came up with this, he had been at
Paradise Garage, dancing all night on acid,
and he came home and he drew it.
And so, it totally captures that.
I love this piece by Scott Covert.
It's a human skull.
I don't know where he got the human skull,
but he got it.
We had, like, an obsession with death.
We had a rock group called Youth Against Death.
It was a fake rock group.
We were too cool to play any instruments or
have any songs, but we actually got booked
in some clubs.
Scott would decorate these skulls, and I think
they're very powerful.
I think it was almost a precursor for what
is to come, this kind of lingering sense of
death.
This video, Tom Rubnitz was an incredible
film maker.
And Ann had been working on all of these characters,
like, this is Tammy Jan, and PTL Club was
happening.
And so, she really riffed on TV.
Here, we have Richard Hambleton.
He recently died, but he...Shadows started
appearing all over New York, and Richard would
go out at night and he would paint shadows
in doorways.
But they were very eerie, and he did them
'til the day he died.
Here we have Dan Asher, who was the craziest
person I've ever met in my life.
He was something, he was crazy.
Good crazy, but he was something else, let
me tell you.
And here's Archie, he would take jewels and
he would bejewel everything.
And, at this time, you have to understand
that, like, minimalism and conceptual art
was what was happening.
And so, for somebody to decorate a minimal
circle was very radical.
Here we have Bruno Schmidt and Peter Hristoff.
We were all in art school together.
But, as you can see, things became very sexual.
It was the end of the sexual revolution, right
before AIDS hit, and I think male sexuality
was really coming into the public eye, and
it was gay male, gay male transgressive images
that really came out of it.
I mean, you know, being a queer was no fun
until, you know, yesterday.
You should come and see the show, it's amazing,
and it really touches my heart because it
gives people that do not have the voice today
a place.
They were so important, they were so incredible,
and they created beautiful works.
And, thanks to Ron, thanks to Sophie, and
Ann Magnuson, John Epperson, they put this
together, and I think you really get a feeling
for the Club in this space.
Low ceilings, dark, it's nota white gallery,
and it is mixed media, it is everything was
possible.
So, thank you for spending a little time with
me, and I hope you'll see it.